MATT FURNISS: There's eight
games today, so there's one
early game kicking off in
15 minutes, QPR-Norwich.
Then six games at 3 o'clock,
and then one late
game at half 5:00.
So yeah, it'll get busy
around 3 o'clock.
We are the content and customer
service team, so we
will provide all the stats
for our Twitter
feeds, for our clients.
Editorially, we'll be doing
features, packs for TV
companies, sending everything
out to the newspapers.
Whereas the guys in the other
room in the operation's team,
they'll b recording all the
data, and they will be, sort
of handling everything that
goes on behind the scenes.
We can't plan what's
going to happen.
We have a set routine of
things we need to do.
We have a list of everything
we need to do, but, I mean,
football is unpredictable.
You can never tell what's
going to happen.
So this is our analysis room.
At the moment, they're analyzing
the game live.
We have a guy for each
team and a checker.
So if anyone has any questions
about the dates they're
putting in, they'll flag it up,
and then the checker can
check by just going back,
replaying the footage, and
then re-inputting the data.
On certain games, we record
about 1,800 actions a game,
so, I mean around 900 a team.
Obviously it's going to be a lot
more if you're analyzing
Barcelona than you are Stoke
or QPR or Norwich.
We have about 200 applications
every summer
for operations guys.
Maybe four or five will get
through to the final section
where they'll be trained up.
I mean, hand-eye coordination
has to be amazing.
I couldn't do this myself.
I'm too slow.
But these guys, I mean, a
few of them have been
here for a few years.
So they build up a great skill
set to be able to do this.
SAM GREEN: I definitely
could not do it.
And I know the hand-eye
coordination they have, so
it's a pretty intense--
you've got to be doing it.
It's live.
You're 45 minutes late.
They've got a little bit of
time to go back and check
errors during the breaks, and we
obviously go through every
match after it's happened.
But while they're doing it, it's
a pretty intense 45, 50
minutes at a time where you
don't have much let-up, and
it's a pretty impressive
demonstration of skills.
I'm not sure what skills, and
how they've built them up, but
it is more than I can
do, certainly.
MATT FURNISS: It takes a
unique kind of person.
I mean, if you're good at
computer games, it helps.
And you have to have a really,
really good knowledge of
football as well.
So the speed at which everything
happens, you have
to be able to tell which player
is which, at least in a
blink of an eye.
So if someone is wearing yellow
boots, you might be
able to say that means
that's that player.
And sometimes, I mean, you might
have Rafael and Fabio,
two twins on the team.
So you've got to know the
characteristics of
each player as well.
Despite they're both from
different wings, if something
was to come into the box, you
might need to know if one
wears white boots, one has
tape around his socks or
something like that.
So yeah, you can pick that up.
A lot of it is communication.
If one of them has a question,
he might say
can you double check.
A defender may have made a
clearance, but it might have
been a long ball instead.
So they'd ask to check it to
just check that replay, and
then if it needs correcting,
correct it straight away.
They'll say, here we can replay
the data, and they can
double check and
pause and see.
So quite often, if there's a
deflection on a goal, and
we're not sure if it's a known
goal, we can then slow it
down, replay it, pause it, so
we can take different angles
and have a look at whether it
is a known goal or not.
Luckily, the early game today
is a dull affair between QPR
and Norwich.
I say that now, and when you
film again at nine minutes,
it'll be 4-0.
But yeah, I mean, there's not
much going on at the moment
until something big
happens, maybe a
goal, red card, penalty.
We're liaising.
We have commentators for the
game across the world
providing them with
facts and data.
So yeah, just waiting for
something big to happen, and
then we can get down
and do our job.
BRADY HARAN: How common is it
that you will pull together
some fact or amazing piece of
trivia, send it off from your
computer, and then you hear it
come across on the TV a minute
or two later?
MATT FURNISS: Yeah,
quite often.
I mean, there was a famous one
in the World Cup a few years
ago when Rob Green disastrously
let Clint
Dempsey's shot through his
hands against the USA.
And straightaway, our team
were on to it, and we
remembered that he'd actually
made the most mistakes leading
to goals in the Premier League
that season as well.
ITV mentioned it, and we were
being told on [INAUDIBLE] that
across the world, commentators
were mentioning our fact that
it was an [INAUDIBLE].
So that was a really
nice moment for us.
And then, yeah, you
quite often--
I see Mark's doing
the commentator
support at the moment.
You'll hear something that he's
just put across to them
within 30 seconds.
So that's as quick as
is it can happen.
So say if now there's a red
card, we could research a fact
about that red card.
Say it might be the player's
eighth red card.
I need two players.
I've got more.
Or they're the team with the
most red cards this season.
We could put that straight to
the commentator, and then they
can have it out and mention it
on screen within a minute.
So, I mean, while the action is
fresh and while the stat is
fresh, they'll have
it out there.
BRADY HARAN: The commentators
sound so knowledgeable when
they do that.
Does that frustrate you and
make you think, you
didn't do know that.
That was because of
me or is that--
MATT FURNISS: In fairness, the
commentators do a lot of
research before the game.
We're helping them out.
That's our job.
QPR just won a penalty.
Norwich had given it away.
So I can have a quick look now
to see how many penalties have
been given this season for each
side using our database.
Right.
So we can have a quick look now
to see Norwich's record
this season running a report.
This season, QPR have
won two penalties.
Both of them have been against
Norwich, home and away, and
they've had both
of them saved.
SAM GREEN: QPR has now
had the last three
penalties in a row saved.
So I'll put that straight
through now to this guy who's
doing the commentary.
The decision to retain a player
or sign a player is, I
mean, it's literally a
multimillion pound or euro or
dollar or whatever, it's a
multi-million something
investment.
I can't imagine many other
walks of life, many other
businesses where you would
just take that based upon
someone's feel and intuition,
and you'd have someone sitting
there watching them
do their job.
It doesn't make sense.
You'd normally have numbers in
some way of quantifying that.
MATT FURNISS: The game ended in
a board draw, not the best
for our analysis.
There's not too much
to talk about.
So we're trying to
put together some
page-matched facts now.
QPR, now five unbeaten in the
Premier League, which is the
best run in the Premier League
since March '95.
And obviously, want to to know
about how Harry Redknapp has
drawn more games nil-nil than
any other manager in the
Premier League, 62nd that was.
What we do now is we just put
together the page-matched
facts, save all the stats for
the game, send them out to the
media, and then just wait for
the 3 o'clock games and the
fun to start.
I'd say it's been an
above-average day for action.
There's quite a lot going on.
There's six games
at the moment.
Lukas Podolski just scored for
Arsenal, but it seems to be
disallowed.
But, yeah, I mean, it's
been pretty hectic.
I mean, there's a flurry of
goals around the midway point
of the first half, so yeah,
there's been right plenty of
stuff coming out today,
so yeah, it's good.